fabrice est belle pour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors
conforme à condition de muscler les
garanties de protection des libertés et
d'évaluer régulièrement son utilité
c'est l'avis de la commission nationale
de l'information et des libertés
alors comment le comprendre c'est une
mise en garde claire sur le risque d nos
respects des libertés individuelles
selon vous j'avais la clé il a un avis
consultatif il a toujours été
consultatif et qu'il ne sert pas
fondamentalement orienter la politique
nécessaire avoir éventuellement des
garde-fous tout comme le conseil
national le numérique mais lui aussi son
avis est consultatif de toute façon le
gouvernement avance rails pour l'instant
il ne prend pas la pire des directions
même si c'est pas forcément direction
qui aura des effets sur l'épidémie et il
ya beaucoup d'états dormir qui ont pris
des directions infiniment pire pour ce
qui est de traquer leurs populaires pas
la pire des directions c'est à dire que
il y aura des garanties légales et
techniques qui ont vont être mises en
place c'est cela si jamais cette
application est votée alors les
garanties légales et techniques sont
deux choses totalement différentes
jusqu'ici il n'y a jamais eu de réelles
garanties légales parce que encadrer la
technologie par la loi
c'est un exercice extrêmement complexe
et auquel jusqu'ici la semaine nationale
a systématiquement échoué des garanties
techniques et à quelques-uns mais de
toute façon le projet est en cours
d'évolution et puis il faut prendre un
peu de recul sur la situation on a d'un
côté une application peut être par
l'état sous la direction de débris dont
on connaît à peu près les les contours
techniques mais on sait d'ores et déjà
que orange travaille de son côté sur une
application et on n'a pas la moindre
idée comment elles marchent allait
certainement beaucoup plus intrusif
mais d'autres chantiers sont à l'oeuvre
avec capgemini d'assaut y compris des
sociétés beaucoup plus grand public
comme voisine qui travaillent pas
seulement sur le bracelet électronique
on aura à mettre à 100 volontairement
pas donc on est pour l'instant dans une
multitude de chantiers dont le seul sur
lequel on a une idée relativement
précise et celui qui a été ébauchée il
ya de ça deux semaines par cédric augé
secrétaires d'état au numérique et qui a
de toute façon et vous voulez
suffisamment pour d'ores et déjà alerté
beaucoup monde
sans même parler de cette problématique
de relation des goliath alors est ce que
cette dernière application on peut
imaginer des intérêts privés ou
politique ou politiques pardon vous vous
6/3 des entreprises qui travaillaient
déjà sur le dossier
alors il ya des intérêts bien sûr pour
gagner des marchés ou tout simplement
pour s'imposer comme une alternative à
ces technologies américaines qui pour
l'instant semble totalement
incontournable
il est assez invraisemblable de se
passer de google et d'apple et ça
revient à regarder en face le rôle la
position de ces entreprises par rapport
aux états google apple aujourd'hui
propose quelque chose que dans l'idéal
on aurait bien aimé vu porté par l'om
est typiquement mais l'état de la queue
aujourd'hui il n'y a que google et apple
qui sont en mesure de faire ce genre de
solution et la france n'est pas en
mesure de proposer une alternative à
l'est pas en mesure de réunir comme
google apple centaine de pays
parce que tout simplement elle domine
ses marchés qu'elle peut imposer ses
solutions sur la terre entière du coup
si c'est google et apple qu'est ce que
pourraient devenir les données dans la
période durant laquelle l'application
serait disponible mais aussi après et il
n'y a pas de risque des malades pour
l'instant il n'y a pas vraiment de
soucis à avoir de ce côté là le
véritable souci à avoir c'est de
regarder en face le fait qu'aujourd'hui
les états son vis-à-vis d'apple et de
google dans la dans une dépendance plus
forte encore quelle leçon vie david oms
et dans une une incapacité de
souveraineté par rapport à des choses
qui sont des entreprises mais qui ne
sont plus vraiment des entreprises on
l'a vu avec facebook au préalable mais
c'est les gars fans ne sont plus
vraiment des entreprises ne sont pas
tout à fait des états mais sont une
espèce d'hybride et c'est une occasion
de regarder ça en face de façon
extrêmement violente parce que pour une
fois il ne s'agit pas de lutter contre 1
ou de construire des alternatives
nous sommes dans l'urgence la
construction d'alternatives et
invraisemblable la construction d'un
consensus il est invraisemblable dans
des temps aussi court
du coup il n'y a pas d'autre solution
que de s'en remettre à ses entités qui
j'insiste ne sont plus vraiment d
entreprise et c'est quelque chose de
particulièrement douloureux à assumer
notamment pour tout un tas d'état dont
la france qui jusqu'ici
des d'un air on va dire maîtrisant
toutes les velléités de souveraineté
numérique et qui s'aperçoit
qu'effectivement on l'a intégralement
perdu merci beaucoup fabrice epelboin
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes spécialiste des
médias sociaux et enseignant à sciences
po